right before covid two years ago I was a
speaker for your fyf not uh not the
president I was speaking at a member
campus is one of which was Stanford
three of the students who invited me to
uh to speak there I spoke with
beforehand I asked them all sorts of
questions but one of them was how you
became a conservative two of the three
very normal but the third gentleman said
oh no my parents are Democrats I said
well how did you become a conservative
we happened to be in his dad's truck a
number of times by himself driving
places and would listen on the radio and
he found some some conservative talk
radio folks that he liked listening to
he read what they talked about he read
books by the time he went to Stanford
his mother's alma mater he was a full
spectrum conservative he was a Believer
he got into this that's a great story
but what makes it powerfully optimistic
is John's mother John rice Cameron's
mother happens to be none other than
Susan Rice I look at that and say if
Susan's rice if only given the
opportunity to hear the truth to hear
the facts can actually become a full
spectrum conservative There's Hope for
every Young person in America if we can
just get to them and I think we can
this is the 45th governor of the great
state of Wisconsin and currently the
president of Young Americans Foundation
Scott Walker welcome back to the Reuben
report
great to be back Dexter Maryland I'm
glad to talk to you today because we are
only a few days out from these very
strange midterm elections uh strange do
you like my adjective Choice there or do
you have a better one
I do no I'm with you on strange I think
you're right it's not it's not bad it's
not good it's just strange it's a great
way to say it what do you what's your
takeaway I mean you know everyone said
this Red Wave was a comment I kind of
was saying it myself but I kept saying
you know you can't count your chickens
before they hatch and all that stuff and
obviously we still have a couple races
that haven't been announced as of us
taping this right now but but what's
your main takeaway
well a couple different things it's not
as big of a win for Republicans as many
people thought but taking the house at a
minimum if that's where we end up being
I think is a good thing because it
obviously slows the horrendous horrific
and almost existential threat that we
have out of Washington uh with the bite
Administration is lackey's there so if
for nothing else if there's at least
enough votes uh to make some other than
Nancy Pelosi the speaker that's a good
thing to counter things I think one of
the big takeaways though I took out of
Tuesday was uh that ideas matter and
that it's not enough just to say you're
against Joe Biden the polls
overwhelmingly show dissatisfaction with
the way Joe Biden's acting the way
they're handling the accounting or not
handling it so I think unfortunately a
lot of candidates on the right thought
well we just we'll talk about how bad
Biden is and we'll just run as not being
Biden and I'm voters one and more and to
prove that case I would tell you that
where there were big wins is every
incumbent Republican governor in the
country not only one in their
re-elections they won big and in many
cases saved some of the Senate
candidates Ohio's a prime example JD
Vance may not have won that race if it
had been for Mike dewine when they're
like big time Herschel Walker might not
have been in a runoff in this Georgia
Senate race had Brian KIPP not win going
away and you know other governors sunodu
in a Battleground state where
unfortunately we didn't get as close as
we thought New Hampshire won big there
Kim Reynolds in Iowa and obviously the
two big ones Ron DeSantis in Florida and
Greg Abbott in Texas I mean the big
winners on Tuesday were Republican
governors in large part because they
didn't just talk about Biden they
actually talked about how to lead and
they acted on him were you surprised
that there were wasn't more anger to
some of kind of the the Democrat
quote-unquote stars of the pandemic I
mean a Gretchen Whitmer who had some of
the worst lockdowns and hypocritical
moves in her personal life during it or
you know it's not like Gavin Newsom is
going to lose but you know him in
California or even Hotel in New York who
nobody voted for first time around
because she obviously came in after
Cuomo was taken out but that they didn't
pay any price really
no I I was surprised uh in that regard I
think particularly in Michigan because
we all still kind of hoped that that was
a Battleground State I think after
Tuesday not just the governor's race but
you look at the even the Regent
positions in the University system I
mean it has sadly become a sadly Blue
State in Michigan almost the flip side
of Ohio which used to be a Battleground
State and is pretty consistently
Republican now
um although you look at other Governors
I mean the Democrat Governor in Colorado
uh who I disagree with on other issues
was arguably one of the better ones when
it came to the lockdown that he got
rewarded with a huge win there so yeah
polish did for sure and and I think
obviously the big winners of Florida and
Texas are good examples of people who
and I would say just governors in
general not just DeSantis and Abbott but
they were the most visible ones and
remember the tractors said oh people are
going to die they had a guy dressed up
as a grim reaper on the beaches in in
Florida in Beto said oh people are going
to be dead because of Greg Abbott no
they got their states open they only got
their economy back on track their kids
if you look at the scores are doing
arguably much better than kids in states
that were shut down but sadly Michigan
New York and California are probably now
in the foreseeable future pretty solid
blue States and people there even though
the facts are right in front of them
apparently at least in these elections
weren't willing to budge from that
do you miss any of the of the game
obviously two-time Governor you ran for
president you know now you're you're
doing your thing with Young Americans
but do you miss the fights I mean when
it's election night or you're like ah I
should have got back in or I should be
doing this or that
my wife was actually all excited about
that she used to hate those nights when
I was a candid she was all excited about
it Tuesday I'm like who are you what
have you done to my wife uh but uh I
don't actually I don't miss the campaign
stuff the election night the nerves uh
certainly when I saw some of the tv ads
in Wisconsin and elsewhere across the
country I don't miss that one of the
things I always felt I would miss and I
do are some of the people although I'm
blessed at Young America's Foundation to
bump into not only in my state Wisconsin
but across the country some of the same
sorts of folks and obviously being with
these Brave heroic high school college
and now middle school students who are
trying to stand out on their campuses
and schools as conservatives is very
rewarding I think the biggest thing I I
found during covet people said to me oh
it must be nice not to be governor and
that was my initial reaction but after a
couple months of fools across the
country in my state and elsewhere
locking things down as you can imagine
here I just looked in and said we could
be doing so much better people always
ask me what would I have gone and I look
at not only DeSantis and Abbott but
Christy gnome is another example in
South Dakota it said I would have put my
trust in the people give people
information let them know what the what
the circumstances are but have your put
enough faith in the American people and
the people in each state to let them
make the right decisions for themselves
their families their children uh
Governors and and for that matter Mayors
and others who did that and their
jurisdictions are doing far better than
those that lock things down I don't know
if you happen to see it but there was an
article a couple weeks ago in the
Atlantic about pandemic amnesty did you
happen to catch that or see any of The
Firestorm around that
I I did a little bit I didn't read the
article but I I did I did see that uh so
so broadly the idea that all that 2020.
yeah so the idea of amnesty this idea
that we should just sort of forgive
everybody who did all of these you know
massive government overreach things and
that we let bureaucrats trample on the
Constitution and all these things I
suspect from a Yale studio uh you're not
really in the mood for amnesty
no and and I think it's as you and I
know uh sometimes not only in politics
but in life in general when when you
come to a crisis that's when people
reveal themselves to be who they truly
are and we saw that during the pandemic
the people who not only rushed to put
the government in control of things to
in many ways disregard the state and
federal constitutions you know the
Constitution doesn't have a clause for
an emergency it's there no matter what
and there are a lot of people trampled
all over that thinking oh it's an
emergency it's emergency no that's
exactly why you have a constitution is
so that uh so you know self-proclaimed
emergencies don't take the day that's
what you have in dictatorships and
oppressive regimes around the world we
don't have that in the United States we
should never forget that we should never
allow something like this uh to happen
again and again if you look back
hindsight's always 20 20 but I think
it's very instructive to see the the
governors the Mayors the other officials
who again put their faith in taking
their shoes say I I never once thought
it wasn't a serious issue but who put
their faith in the people I have one of
the big takeaways and I think you have
seen this in some of the exit polling
was I I think post-pandemic there is a
shift it's less about conservative and
and liberal Democrat Republican as it
was post-pandemic about uh blue collar
and white collar jobs I think a lot of
people like my brother who's a manager
at a convenience store in Chained and my
sister-in-law who sells appliances for
Home Depot great good hard-working
people they and other blue collar
workers like them I think became very
turned off towards the the heavy hand of
the government because first it was
their the place they worked at and then
it was their kids schools both of which
they were upset were closed versus sadly
in the suburbs in particular a lot of
white-collar employees who were like I
don't have to commute to work my kids
can each hang out in their bedrooms be
on their on their uh computers all day
in school we spend more time together
this isn't so bad and they were the ones
that kind of bought into giving these
freedoms away I think there's going to
be a long-term shift that reflects a
more severeign voter Sally being open to
government control and more blue collar
workers on their families who are like I
don't ever want this to happen again
speaking of shifts I don't know if
you've seen any of this but a lot of
people are saying that you know gen Z
which is now voting for the first time
that they're all coming in and in
essence you know they're they're sort of
default leftists they've been taught
that socialism is cool that big
government is good you should just be
given stuff and all this it's obviously
counter to the work that you guys do and
I've spoke at many young Americas events
and people are excited about freedom and
all that but but it is an uphill battle
for sure
oh it totally is because it's starting
younger and younger I mean we just took
over in addition to the Reagan Ranch out
in California this last year we took
over the Reagan boy at home in the
middle of the country in Dixon Illinois
where we have conferences but we also
occasionally have tours and school
groups that come through our director
recently told me that some fifth grade
students that were there with a class
trip loved the tour but at one point our
director was talking about how Reagan
his actions as we just recognized this
past week you know November 9th the 33rd
anniversary of the the Berlin Wall
coming down the fall communism he's
talking about communism and the kids
said well what's wrong with Communism
and the guy was like Bill Wilder and
he's like you know we're taught that
that's a system of government that helps
people like no this is not it at all but
it's sadly what we've seen for years on
college campuses we actually have a seat
against the administrators at Clovis
Community College in Fresno California
where during Freedom week last year we
had our chapter there had posters that
were approved pre-approved to put up the
posters showed a woman in the old Soviet
Union standing in a grocery store where
there was no fruit on the shelves which
sadly was pretty frequent back then as
it is in places like Cuba and Venezuela
today and it said got milk got bread got
blankets got anything and it was
obviously making a point about communism
and socialism not working and the the
administrators literally took the
posters down and claimed the reason for
that was because it was offensive the
Communist well hell yeah it's offensive
to Communists that's because they're
wrong it's the truth we got to get the
truth out and it's got to happen sooner
because the indoctrination is happening
younger and younger along the way yeah I
mean it's incredible that that's leaking
into Elementary School at this point but
I suppose it's some level none of this
uh should surprise us going back to a
bit of the resource politics for a
moment uh you know the the big thing in
in Republican politics or in
conservative politics whatever you want
to call it is sort of this this Trump
DeSantis thing that seems to be be
bursting forth whether we like it or not
what's your take and what do you think
is going to happen
well I think it'll be interesting just
because of Ron DeSantis just having to
be re-elected he's obviously going to
focus on being governor in the short
term someday whether it's 2024 2028 at
some point I think you'll run and be an
excellent candidate but that may not be
the worst of all scenarios because I
think it's pretty clear that President
Donald Trump is going to announce
probably within the next week it'll give
him a chance and all the rest of us a
chance to see what happens
if he catches fire again it probably
makes people like DeSantis and others
think twice about running if it's
lukewarm or not good at all maybe it
opens the field not just the DeSantis
but Abbott Christie Noam Nikki Haley
Mike Pompeo Mike Pence Ted Cruz you name
it the whole universe out there and I
think you know as much as I don't talk
and tweet the way that Donald Trump does
I do think he's earned the right based
upon what he did during those four years
as president he is without a doubt
earned the right to be at least at the
top of the list of consideration doesn't
guarantee that he'll win the nomination
or be elected president but I think he's
at least earned it I was suspect early
on but my goodness I mean tax cuts
regular regulatory reform some of the
greatest judicial nominations I've ever
seen even simple things like doing what
nobody else had the guts to do and
moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem maybe there's a whole
cross-section of things that most of us
as conservatives even from the
Libertarians point of view never dreamed
were possible that this guy got
accomplished now does he always talk or
tweet or have the same tone that many of
us do probably not but again I I like
people who do more than just people who
talk and for that he earns a lot of
credit you mentioned I do think at the
flip side of it is he's yeah he's got a
little bit of a challenge though I think
because many of the people that he
endorsed in the primaries either didn't
win or like with Vance wouldn't have won
without the wine and so that'll be part
of the equation as well right and again
as we're taping this we still don't know
what's happening with Carrie Lake and
with Blake Masters and black salt so
some of this could shake out a little
bit better and but we'll kind of see but
since you mentioned the Libertarians
there on Twitter at least there's always
this war with the Libertarians you know
basically do we remain hardcore
Libertarians and only vote for
libertarian candidates or obviously
we're a bit closer to being Republican
certainly the Democrats do we align
there uh again these are all the ideas
that Young Americans Foundation are
talking about all the time what do you
think sort of strategically for the for
the person that's out there that just
it's limited government it's lower no
taxes states rights that's it what do
you think they should be doing
well I think the simple answers don't
ever let the perfect be the enemy of the
very good and by that I don't mean just
universally if you're a Libertarian vote
Republican but I do think don't limit
yourself to solely voting uh libertarian
because while that's great in principle
it doesn't get things done I think
Reagan certainly was a great person at
bringing different coalitions together I
hope during my eight years in office
three elections of which the recall was
one of the biggest in the nation we were
able to do that and we reigned in
Governor one of the biggest frustrations
to me I don't even remember this but a
few years ago Matt Bevin the governor of
the Commonwealth of Kentucky arguably at
the time the most libertarian-like
candidate in the country a guy who
aggressively cut red tape who
aggressively reigned in the government
who cut taxes who took on these big
issues in in Kentucky and he lost that
election just barely in the margin by
which he lost to Brashear the current
governor was less than the margin of
what the libertarian can today for
governor got in that race and so to me
it's just a great reminder I get it with
some of these what some people might
call rhinos people who are like a lot of
government spending who are just a
little bit less bad than than the
Democrat running in the race but in that
case it was a prime example this is a
guy that Libertarians should love this
is a guy that Libertarians you want to
uh should want to replicate around the
country and yet they got behind a
candidate who effectively put set that
margin down and now you got a full-scale
big spending big government Democrat in
there it to me it just doesn't make a
lot of sense don't do it across the
board make those candidates those
Conservative Republican candidates earn
it and then hold them accountable when
they get in the office and I think
Libertarians can make some loyal inroads
that way let's talk about the the other
side of the coin here uh the
progressives have have basically just
taken over the Democrat Party and I
think unfortunately because of the
results that are kind of wishy-washy
this week I think they'll basically feel
emboldened
um do you think there's any stopping
that movement within the Democrat Party
made ice I would imagine I'm not totally
well versed in in Wisconsin politics but
I would imagine you've probably got some
moderate uh or had some moderate uh
Democrats in Wisconsin back in the day
but they they all seem to be gone at a
national level now
well even in the states I mean when I
was governor and certainly years before
a long time ago when I was briefly in
the state legislature but even a few
years ago when I was governor there were
still a few of the kind of traditional
Blue Dog outstate somewhat rural area
Democrats who uh were somewhat moderate
to conservative in some issues but you
know we're aligned with unions and other
things along the way they're gone
they're gone most of those districts
it's one of the unique phenomenas while
the suburbs moved away from Republicans
under President Trump more I think based
on tone than on policy flip side of that
is in a lot of those rural blue-collar
areas around my state and around the
country a lot of those Democrats who'd
held those seats before boy this wave
came in and good solid Republican
candidates won those seats so that shift
has certainly happened in Wisconsin but
I think arguably elsewhere in the
country and nationally uh yeah I mean it
think about this Joe Biden who ran just
a few years ago two and a half years ago
Joe Biden on super Tuesday they was
basically positioning himself as a more
mainstream alternative to Bernie Sanders
he eventually got mayor Pete and and
Senator Klobuchar out of his Lane the
mainstream more moderate Reign because
he knew he had all these other people
you had Bernie and and Elizabeth Warren
and others in the far left wing Lane But
the irony was he did that to win the
primary and then did the opposite of
what traditionally happens he then went
out in the general and ran hard to the
left to get burning an AOC support and
basically outsourced his agenda to them
remember Kamala Harris actually had a
voting record the year before she was
picked that was further to the left than
the the self-proclaimed socialist Bernie
Sanders and he hasn't stopped since
uh what do you make of Biden what's
going on there I mean is he is it all
there what's happening
no and it's not just age I mean it's a
combination you know is is Ronald Wayne
got older even post-presidency and
obviously later at Festus presidency
Alzheimer's if you have an inner core
he's still clone to certain principles
one of my complaints with Joe Biden far
before this presidency was Joe Biden
would do and say anything I mean quite
literally in 87 he got nailed for
plagiarizing a labor leader in over in
Britain almost word for word claiming
his words were the words of himself and
not of that labor leader this guy is
consistently done her so just about
anything to hold the office of President
he ran in the 87-88 election he ran
again in 0-8 obviously ran in 2020. I
think this guy would would knock off his
arm before he gave up the presidency but
I just think that's all the more reason
why he for your last question why he's
not going to back away from this radical
radical agenda he can't do it because if
he he backs away he doesn't have enough
finesse to avoid a primary I think
looking ahead that's probably a good
thing if you compare it to 1980 when we
had similar circumstances uh if he did
back away he'd have what Jimmy Carter
had with Teddy Kennedy and that is a
primary from the left and if he doesn't
unlike Bill Clinton and I think he
doesn't think he had the same problem
Bill Clinton had in the 94 elections I
think he's gonna have a real problem uh
come 2024 but who knows a lot of us
thought things would be a little
different on Tuesday in the elections as
well right and as of the last couple of
days I mean it's not he says he's
running again it's just beyond
imagination but okay so be it so if if
you guys if you were showing up at uh at
a yaf event at a college campus that was
that was heavily Lefty which is pretty
much every single one of them what are
some of the main what are some of the
main ideas you would want to get across
one of the things that I've been talking
about a lot lately are the Federalist
Papers and the idea of states rights and
making sure that you know this
experiment can operate differently so
that there are different places where
things will will be different uh what
are some of the ideas that you would
want to get across to these young kids
well first off one I think we need to
explain it in in terms that apply not
only to the head but the heart I think
that's one of the mistakes conservatives
have made at all ages that we think of
talk with our head the left things and
talks with their heart we need to think
with our head but talk in ways that come
from the heart and so some of our most
powerful speakers at conferences and
increasingly on campuses are people
who've come from either so or not Soviet
excuse me or communist or socialist
marxist-based countries in the past
because they can match the logic of the
argument but tied into Real World
experience we just had a woman who came
for example and spoke to us who came
from North Korea years ago escaped with
her mother through trying up to Mongolia
Beyond me Parts
yeah I mean yeah yeah she's a prime
example we're going to have her out on
campuses for us because I love the
connection of her telling her personal
story it's hard to argue from the left
against things that she can vouch for
things that actually happen we have a
young man speaking this coming weekend
from Venezuela I think we need to do
more of that and match the logic with
the emotion tying the two together but I
also think we have to we have to get
Beyond kind of the the cookie cutter
approach of talking in political terms I
think you're right Freedom isn't just
you know the opposite of socialism isn't
capitalism uh certainly it's free
market-based capitalism it takes the is
much better route than government-driven
socialism but the opposite of socialism
is more than just an economic system
it's fundamental freedoms one of the
ways I talk about it is it's the
difference between an Uber and a taxi
you know taxis are highly regulated
highly restricted they're usually a big
fee or tax assigned to it and they try
to box people off from getting into it
that's like those on the left who want
to tell you what to do when to do and
how to do it they put their faith in the
government our counter should be kind of
like Uber or Lyft which is you know they
don't care whether you drive once a day
or 100 times a day as long as you get
yourself and your passengers safely from
one point to the other
they're successful same of you was a
conservative slash libertarian point of
view is as long as you don't hurt the
health and safety of your neighbor go
out and live your life do your thing I
don't want to tell you what you do with
your business you go pursue your dream
the way you see fit because we believe
in you more than they believe in the
government and I think the more we get
to that fundamental course story uh of
what America is all about it's not just
conservatives it's American idea of the
better off we're going to be with young
people are you guys worried at all that
just the entropy of all this will always
drag things left I mean even right now
if you think about it you know there's a
big movement for school choice happening
on the right so more and more parents
will select out of the main systems
personally I obviously think that's a
good thing and they'll either homeschool
or charter school or pods or whatever it
might be but at the college level that
they're either just not going to go to
college or they will just figure out
other ways to go into the workforce thus
leaving the colleges in essence to the
Socialists
yeah I think it ran both counts I mean
I've said the reaction if you're a
parent being upset about what we've seen
either taught or not taught in our
schools over the last few years
particularly during the pandemic is one
of three things get involved run for
school board take your school board over
do something that takes your Traditional
government-run School and puts it on the
right track go to a private school if
you're in a state like Wisconsin where I
expanded school choice parental school
choice options Statewide send your kid
to a private school with a voucher or
tax credit or other things like that or
if you've got the capacity and the
ability to homeschool but you're right
in those last two options and certainly
when it comes to colleges and
universities that de facto then leaves a
whole NASA people in the government-run
institutions that don't have that don't
have a counter to all that which is
precisely why what we're doing at Young
America's Foundation is so important why
af.org if people are interested and that
is people sometimes say hey do you have
a do you have a a yaf chapter at
Hillsdale we do but I'm like I'm not
worried about Hillsdale
you know I'm worried about so many
public government-run institutions and
so that's why our work is certainly not
done even as people send their kids to
alternatives to the government-run
institutions we've got to fight every
single day and every single one of these
campuses to get the truth out and
remember the irony is you know free
speech is something that's protected by
our constitution but it should be
revered of all places on our college
campuses yet traditionally that's where
we're at the most at risk and so we're
going to fight there we're going to
fight on campus and we get there one of
the best things is we just had Shapiro
Ben Shapiro up the other day at one of
our campus he typically gets not only
thousands of kids on campus even on
these liberal campuses but then we live
stream and we put that stuff up on our
YouTube page you have TV and we
literally have millions of people tune
into those things and so that's how we
get around this other nonsense is
finding social media ways to get around
you know it's the beauty of not having
to go through a limited number of news
sources we can put something up on Yap
TV and other social media sites and
really have an impact that's where we
get right to the students not only in
college high school middle school and
younger what would you say to the high
school kid or I guess to the parents of
the high school kid that that care about
these ideas but they're not ready to not
let the kid go to college or just send
them out into the real world they want
to send them to one of these schools but
then they're just simply looking at the
numbers and they're going man it's now
60 Grand a year to go to I don't know
Syracuse and it's 20 grand a year to go
to a state school like this just does
not work what do you say to those people
well I'd say one increasingly there are
better Alternatives than sending a young
person to a four-year undergraduate
certainly if you want to be an engineer
a doctor a lawyer those are certain
professions where you have to but I
think twice there's a lot of and I wish
I wasn't having to say that but I I
think between the cost the rising costs
which is only going to get worse the the
so-called student debt reduction is only
going to open the door towards more of
these colleges and universities upping
their tuition by 10 grand or more so it
gets offset in that regard but I also
think just the radical indoctrination if
you're going to go though if your kid
your son or daughter grandson or
granddaughter or you as a student are
going to go one of the most important
things whether it's yaf College
Republicans some other conservative
group is surround yourself with as many
like-minded people because you're going
to get exposed to different ideas over
and over again but you want to have a
support network out there the number one
thing we hear at our conference is our
students say oh it's so nice to be
around kids that think the same way we
do and I know with both of my sons who
are 28 and 20 seven now one who went to
a private Jesuit institution which sadly
was woke as well the other went to
University of Wisconsin-Madison which is
left to Berkeley both of them came out
conservatives because of the people they
surrounded themselves with who to this
day are still our allies of theirs I
think that's incredibly important yeah
what do you say to the kids once they
get through it when then they look at
the economy and they go man these jobs
that were being offered we basically we
can't live in big cities because rent is
high and we do want to get out of our
parents basement but seems like
everybody's going back in there
well again that's part of the reason why
I say reluctantly but sadly that that if
you don't have to be in a a profession
where it requires a four-year
undergraduate degree I'd say find some
other Alternatives a lot of folks
community colleges apprenticeships other
means to get into decent paying jobs
with all that student loan debt on top
of it it's a good reminder again why
socialism communism Marxism might sound
good to some on the surface but it just
doesn't work not only in past history it
doesn't work in Venezuela or Cuba today
it's certainly a problem in Hong Kong
we've seen it not that long ago in the
Soviet Union but even in big cities you
see so many big cities with the problems
not only with high prices and out of
control rent or housing costs you see it
with cost of living problems you see it
with crime a lot of our large cities
those are all places where you not just
have Democrat or liberal control you
largely have radicals in charge of these
of these governments and I think that's
got to be the constant pushback the
wake-up call if you're concerned about
all these things stop voting for people
people who embraced these ideas because
you're going to get more of it what do
you think we do about the tension
between I think what's growing between
the urban and Suburban communities you
know Lee zeldin obviously did an
incredible job in New York way better
than anyone thought but he did lose and
I looked at the map you know everybody
was showing the map of New York and if
you look at the map of New York it's red
it's almost all red then there's the New
York City metro area and a little bit
sort of towards Buffalo that's pretty
much it but yet they all have to vote
for one governor and I think that
tension is is almost intractable and
it's not New York's not the only place
with that obviously
no you see in variations uh you see it
even in in the New York metro area the
city-wide you look at the difference the
last three gubernatorial elections I was
just looking at an interesting map today
about that uh where Manhattan the island
there has gotten deeper and deeper blue
uh you see Staten Island's gotten more
and more red and then you see Pockets
based interestingly enough based on on
Epic Trends you see a lot of folks
fleeing Russia that have come into
Southern Brooklyn that actually have
made it a little bit more up into
Republicans you see in the Northeast uh
part of of Queens where you see
according to this map it was some of the
increases in Asian population and that's
made it a little bit more open so you
see these divisions out there uh not
only just political but but by groups of
people coming into the country or coming
into a given region we see it though
Nationwide in my state Wisconsin part of
the reason why the governor's race was
not within reach other than the fact
that the Democrat incumbent spent about
twice as much money as the Republic
talking but was Madison where the state
capitol is at and where the university
is at got much higher percentages now we
have total votes but a much higher
margin for Democrats the suburbs were
still Republican but not as much as they
had been in the past and the out state
was a little bit more open to
Republicans but you see this split
between urban areas becoming
increasingly liberal not even just
Suburban Memorial rule to mid-sized
communities becoming strong steady
strongholds I should say for Republicans
there's just a real division in America
we've got to get past that I would one
of the things we talked to students
about is is countering what the left
does over and over again certainly on
campus but even in society if they
disagree with you they call you a series
of names you're you're racist you're
sexist you're transphobic whatever it is
sometimes it doesn't even matter if
that's the topic you're talking about
that's their way of intimidating people
out of real debate real discussion our
counter for those most of his center
right I can't be coming up with their
own series of names but I think rather
pushing this larger nerve that really is
about Unity saying hey I don't care uh
whether you're black or white young or
old rich or poor I don't care what
you're born here you legally came here
for somewhere else I don't care about
your orientation or anything else what I
care about is that you should have the
same freedoms and the same opportunities
as as I inherited and others have
inherited from our parents and
grandparents that's the American dream
that's a bigger issue than just
conservative or liberal out there and
it's a one that truly does bring people
together because then we can start to
see yeah you know the why is what
matters not the what the what will cause
us to have political and other
differences but if we believe in the why
the idea that that all of us were
created equal that the government didn't
give us these rights that God gave us
these rights and it's the role of the
the government fundamentally to protect
those rights not the least of which your
life liberty The Pursuit of Happiness if
that we agree on then we can debate the
specifics of the what but right now
sadly most places in this country people
don't even agree on what they think the
why is and that's a big problem yeah
it's funny my audience knows I like to
end the show with with some hope and we
we actually play a lot of Ronald Reagan
Clips at the end to give people some
sort of aspirational message I certainly
know that those that type of thing will
work for you but are you you sort of
just answer this but are you hopeful
that if we can if we can teach enough
young people that stuff that that we
will reverse this because I think what's
happening is a lot of people now feel if
you if you believe in Freedom you're
hopeful in red States but the blue State
people are are giving up hope and maybe
they'll just end up moving to the red
States and it is what it is but The Hope
in terms of a national structure I think
is eroding
I I'm 100 helpful and I'll tell you one
quick story why uh right before covid
two years ago I was a speaker for your
fyf not uh not the president I was
speaking at a member campus is one of
which was Stanford uh three of the
students who invited me to uh to speak
there I spoke with beforehand I asked
them all sorts of questions but one of
them was how you became a conservative
two of the three very normal but the
third gentleman said oh no my parents
are Democrats I said well how did you
become a conservative we happened to be
in his dad's truck a number of times by
himself driving places and would listen
on the radio and he found some some
conservative talk radio folks that he
liked listening to he read what they
talked about he read books by the time
he went to Stanford his mother's alma
mater he was a full spectrum
conservative he was a Believer he got
into this that's a great story but what
makes it powerfully optimistic is uh
John's mother John rice Cameron's mother
happens to be none other than Susan Rice
I look at that and say if Susan's rice
if only given the opportunity to hear
the truth to hear the facts can actually
become a full spectrum conservative
There's Hope for every young person in
America if we can just get to them and I
think we can so the question really is
is Susan Rice son working on her that's
really the the question that we must be
asking
whether we'll find out well he's a good
guy exactly he loves his parents he just
thinks they're wrong and thank God he
got exposed to the truth
governor Scott Walker I appreciate the
time and all the work you're doing thank
you very much
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell